お願いします
[拍手]
はい
えーとですね大阪経済大学卒業生のプロ
ニートの原田こと原田直ですよろしくお
願いしますはい
早速ちょっとね
座りますね
立ってると力が出ないんですよねはいと
いうことでちょっといきなりプロニートっ
ていう肩書きの人が出てきてどういう
ことって思ってるかもしれないんです
けれども
えっとですね今日は皆さんに
働くなとか
プロニートになれるとかそういうねプロ
ニートを量産するために
来たわけではないので
安心してください
全然そういうわけではなくですね私が
社会に出て働いていた時と今プロニートが
56年目なんですけどその
期間を合わせて
気づいた大切なことを皆さんに今日はお
伝えしたいなと思っておりますということ
でまずは経歴の方はですねこちら見て
ください
出身は愛媛県です
愛媛でここまで過ごしてでなんとなく都会
に出たいなっていうことので大阪経済大学
に入学しました何校か受けたんですけど
受かったところの中で一番
梅田から近かったんですねここがなんで
あのそういう理由で
ざっくりとした理由でこちらを
入学してでゼミとかにも入らずに本当に
ぶらぶらぶらぶらしてる感じだったんです
けど2009年に2回戦の冬ぐらいに芸能
事務所に所属しましたこれいきなりどうし
たって感じなんですけど高校
ぐらいの時からブログを書いてたんですよ
でそのブログが結構なんかアクセス数が
増えてきてそういうお話ができたのでその
ご縁があって
タレントを活動と大学生を
続けましたで何年生かな3年生ぐらいの時
にあの
台形で良かったっていう思い出がいっぱい
あるんですけど
ラウンドワンのね
イメージがイメージガールみたいにお仕事
をしてた時期があったんですねでその時に
外せない授業とその
ラウマの仕事が
被っちゃった時があったんですよであの
これは単位
落とすなこれはでも仕事は休めないしこれ
は単に無理だなと思ってたらあのー
偶然そこの
東淀川店わかりますラウンドワンの
あるんですよねすぐそこにあそこが撮影
場所に
偶然決まったんで
授業を受けた後にチャリでそこのラウワン
まで行ってどっちも
間に合ったっていうちょっとラッキーな
思い出がありますはいそして
12年に卒業してそこから
東京に
上京してから
ちょいタレント活動を
続けました
ゴッドタンとかお願いランキングさんとか
結構バラエティ系多めのお仕事をしてまし
たで
2016年いっぱいで
事務所を辞めて
プロニートになりましたはい
下の写真なんですけどあの一番左のやつ
台形大パーカーってるんですよ今もあるの
が全然知らないんですけどちょっとね
思い出の
プリクラですはいそして
トヨニートになるって書いてますけどどう
いうことだっていう定義が一応あるんです
けど
こちらです
プロニートとは
働かずに好きなことをして収益を得て
暮らすことですはいこれはなんか私が
名乗り始めた時はそんなにこの定義は
固まってなくてなんかただのネットミー
ムっていう感じだったんですけど
ちょいちょいちょいちょいプロニートと
名乗る人が結構増えてきてでなんか定義も
ねこんな感じで
固まってきたんですよはいなので私もこの
定理でやってますそして
プロリートってあのその働かずに
好きなことをしてるって言ってるぐらいな
んで100人0人とかいたら100人違う
ことやってるっていう感じなんですねなの
で私は何をしてるのかっていうはいこちら
ことをしております
ネット配信ハンドメイド
ショップオンラインサロン
ほらむその他諸々メディア出演という感じ
で結構バラバラなんですけどこれらは全部
好きなことやりたいことをその時その時で
やってみているという
感じですはいそしてこれが
1日ねどういう生活してるかってよく聞か
れるので今日は
円グラフにしてみましたはいあのこれあの
水色と青と緑のところは
全部デッドの上にいますだいたい寝てます
大丈夫ですよはいこれもうほとんど寝てて
であとはまあだいたいネットネットネッ
トって書いてあるんですけど
基本的にスマホ中学なんでネットを巡回し
ながらご飯食べたり家事をしたりで夜
ピンクのところでネット配信をしたりとか
そういう生活をしています
本当にだから
基本的にね
ニートの生活と思ってもらって大丈夫です
でこの生活で
稼げるのかっていう話なんですけど
稼げないですそんなにでは生活は遅れて
ますなんであの普通に働いた方がいいって
思う人ももちろんいると思いますなんで
あの私がそれでもこの生活をしている理由
っていうのがメリットをまとめてみたん
ですけれどもこちらです
電話目覚まし電車移動なしこのストレス
フリー3点セットが私にとって
めちゃくちゃ大きいメリットなんですね
これの
本当にお仕事してた時に
電話がいきなりかかってくるので
嫌じゃないですかねあれがすごい私
ノイローゼみたいになっちゃってなんか
こう電話が鳴ってないのになんかなってる
ような気がする
みたいな
ぐらいまで行ってしまって
すっごいなんかそれがストレスだったん
ですねでそこから5年ぐらい今の生活して
てそういうストレスから解放されたんで
すごくねあの行きやすい
感じですねそして一番下肩書きでハードル
が下がっているから何をしても褒められる
これですねあのー
プロニートという肩掛けで活動してたら
時間守っただけでなんかすごいみたいな
こと言われるんですよ
なのに時間守るんですねみたいな
感じで言われたりだとかあとはなんか
多分朝苦手だと思うんで夕方ぐらいの集合
しましょうとかってこう
相手の方からねあの気を使っていただけ
たりとかそういうメリットが結構あります
はいそしてですねこちらまあ
先ほどの一言で言うととにかく行きやすい
というね一言ですこれうちの猫です
無視かっていう猫ですはいそしてですね今
からこちら
プロニートで入れるためのマイルールま
さっきの円グラフみたいに
ダラダラダラダラまあ過ごしてるわけなん
ですけれどもやっぱり決まり事が自分の中
で少しはないとやっぱりやっていけないの
で3つのまぁルールを作っています1つ目
ロード意識を持たないこれはですね
やっぱりさっきも言ったんですけど
好きな事っていうテーマがあるので
とか任務感を持ってしまうとやらされてる
感がなんか無理やりやらされてるかな出
ちゃうじゃないですかそういうのは
見てる人たちにもわかると思うので
自分にも見てる方々にも
嘘をつかないようにやりたいことをやり
たい時にやっているよっていうスタンスは
絶対に崩さないようにしていますそして2
闇ロードをしない
影で働いていたらそれはニートではない
これは
バイトとかねそういうのをやって生活を
持たせているんだったらもうやれちないっ
ていう話なんでバイトとかはしないように
してますだから芸人さんがやってはいけ
ないのが
闇営業とかありましたけど
プロニーとかやってはいけないのは
闇ロードというねことですはいそして3先
の予定を作らないこれはですね
常に
暇で入れることで
色々とね
あのフットワークが軽くなるという話です
ねはいでここで皆さんにクイズです
いきなり参加していただきますはい
えっとですねあのこの3つの中で
先ほど最初に話した皆さんにお伝えしたい
こと深掘りしていきたいことの
項目が1個あるんですけれどもどれ
でしょうかっていうクイズを出したいと
思いますではおさらいしますね1ロード
意識を持たないにやめロードをしない3先
に予定を作らないさ深掘りしていくのは
どれでしょうかということで拍手で答えて
いきたいんですけれどもいいでしょうか
いいですかはいじゃあ1の動画の方初お
願いしますありがとう
ございますで2番と思う方
少な少なくないいいですねありがとう
ございますだんだん先のやつ作らない人
[音楽]
また
多いですねありがとうございますご協力
ありがとうございますはい
えー答えは3段先の予定を作らないという
ことですねはいこれはもう本当に私が
ずっと活動してきて本当にですね
暇が大切だなっていう
結論に至ったんですよなのでこれをねあの
どうしてかっていう具体的な
理由というか具体的な事例を
紹介していきますその1
曲がったからできたこと
Instagramのフィルター制作と
いうことでこの下にある写真全部私の顔で
私が作った
フィルターで撮った
様々なちょっと恥ずかしいんですけど写真
なんですけれどもこういうやつを自分で
作ってインスタのストーリーに公開する
ことができるんですねでそれをシェアされ
ていてみんなが使うっていうやつなんです
けどこの
多分ね
右から2番目の
城之内フィルターっていうのが
結構バズってて
多分大学生の皆さんとかだったら誰かの
ストーリーで見たことあるかもしれない
ですこれをやったことで何があったかって
いうことが
インスタのフォロワー数が約1万人ぐらい
増えましたはいそしてこの顔の造形を
動かす
仕組みが3Dモデリングなんですけどそれ
をこう面白がって使ってたらですね3D
モデリングの技術が勝手に身についてまし
た
左下に
安眠枕ちゃんっていう私の考えた
キャラクターがいるんですけどこれもあの
3Dモデリングの技術を応用して
絵じゃなくてこう
立体で作った
枕ちゃんですこういうのがなんか勝手に
できるようになってきましたそして
制作ソフトがですね
英語しか対応してなかったので日本語で
こういう風に作れますよっていうHow
to動画を出したところ
結構重要があってありがたがられた
的な良かったことがありますそれでこれを
作り始めたのが2年ぐらい前なんですけど
今ですね
フィルターの私のフィルターの総
インプレッション数が
1.9億回らしいんですよ
もうなんか意味わからない
桁なんですけどなんか海外の人もね
Instagramで使うのですごく世界
的にシェアされてて
すごくねあの
面白い
状況になりましたはいそしてその2が
こちらです
話題の場所ものをすぐ配信できるという私
ネット配信やってるって言ったと思うん
ですけどこれ
配信のサムネイル画像っていうやつですね
で
赤の他人の証の写真のガチャガチャがバ
ズってたとか
わたあめの自動販売機ができたとか
話題のゲームを最速で実況するよみたいな
こういう
配信とかをやってるんですけどやっぱり暇
じゃないと
話題になったその日に行けないわけですよ
ねで
それでよかったことっていうのがまあ
毎日ね
起きてから今日何しようかなという考え
てるレベルなのでその日にやることが
決まってないからまバズってる場所にすぐ
行ける
朝まあ朝起きてないですけど
ヒレに起きてその本を見てでなんか面白
そうなのがバズってるなーって思って
じゃあこの後行こうかなみたいなことが
できますそしてやっぱりそういうのってバ
ズってるうちに
移動しないとあの
全然あのアクセスとかもね
埋もれていってしまうので
暇だったら暇なだけあの得なんじゃないか
なと思いますそして
ニュース感覚でそういった動画方とかも見
てくれる人も増えるというよかったことが
ありますあとですね
去年私あのマンホールの
写真を撮って社会貢献しようっていう
アプリがあるんですけど
ご存知ですか
あぶなんですか
のなんか
取ればそれだけ賞金がもらえるよみたいな
のがあったんでもうこれはプロニートの
出番なんじゃないかって思ってもうスマホ
とモバイルバッテリー片手に
繰り出して1日にマンホール400個
ぐらいだったんですよ
でもやっぱり時間があれあのね働いてる人
とは桁違いにあるんで
めちゃめちゃ撮ってであの
賞金とかももらえたりとかなんか
マンホールの人みたいな感じで
インタビューを受けたりだとかこれはマジ
で暇で良かったっていうエピソードです
はいということでまあ今まで
結構ねあのプロ兄さんの話をしてきたん
ですけれども一言で今日の話をまとめると
こちらになります
暇は最強の武器はいこの一言でまとめれる
んじゃないかなと思うんですけれど
もこの言葉をね皆さんぜひ今日もうこれ
だけでいいですなんかマンホールの話とか
も忘れちゃっていいんでこの一言だけ
覚えて帰ってほしいですはい
多分学生さんとかが
聞いてる方多いと思うんであのこれからね
社会に出ていく方々なんで今からねその
暇を作っていけっていうのはなかなかね
あの
会社入ったばっかりの頃とか忙しいと思う
のでそれは全然あの無理しないで大丈夫な
んですけど
色々覚えてちょっと落ち着いた時とかに
なんか
プロニートの人がなんか言ってたなーって
思い出していただけてそれでまああの
ちょっと試してもらったら皆さんの人生が
少し
生きやすくなるんじゃないかなと思って
おりますはいということでこれが私の
プロニクロでした皆さんご視聴ありがとう
ございました
[拍手]